gender neutral toy sections The Daily
Mail has more Reading California
retailers that refuse to have a gender
neutral section for children will be
find up to $500 under Gavin Newsome's
new bill the ultra woke Governor signed
legislation in 2021 that would require
some retail stores in the Golden State
to have a gender neutral section for
children retailers would have to do this
regardless of whether they've been
traditionally marketed for either girls
or for boys the bill said the
legislation will be enacted on January
1st 2024 and if retail department stores
choose not to comply they will have to
dish out a civil penalty of $250 or $500
the bill will uh end the segregated
aparti like conditions and toy stores in
the state getting rid of gender labels
and allowing toys to express their true
gender fluid identities this is all
meant to reduce harmful stereotypes